[Musique]
oh c'est maman ok allô madame on est
Milie qu'est-ce que tu veux pour Nol
j'ai déjà ce que je veux le grand
amour Jess je pense que je te freine tu
es en train de rompre avec
moi bébé on a bien fait les choses tu
sais des disputes propres et du sex sale
tu as une bonne petite chatte toujours
si gourmande je sera ravi de continuer à
satisfaire tes désirs si tu es en
manque je viens de parler à SH rompre
avec toi juste avant Noël ouais SHW ne
veut pas venir à la maison peu importe
mais tu fais partie de notre
famille Monsieur et Madame
C je me sens bien ici
[Musique]
ok le chien PAO viens ici oh mais
bonjour moi c'est David j'ai hérité du
titre de neveu tante l si tu étais 2 ans
plus jeune je sais pas si je pourrais me
retenir e Becky ça fait plaisir de te
voir tu te souviens quand on était gosse
j'ai versé tout mon pot de biscuit sur
toi je devrais plutôt rentrer et
m'occuper de des éclairages tu es resté
planté là depuis le début bonjour
oui j'espère que Jessie passe de bons
moments il s'amuse maintenant tu vas me
goûter ceci et c'est sans danger
profitons simplement du moment et
dégustons ce bon verre de Line ensemble
j'ai rien fait d'ussi improvisé une
éternité on sent bien le sirop pour la
tout là comme ça plus que le soda il a
une robe très riche c'est tout match pas
du tout main non ESS de péchud le cousin
de Shun là on a affaire à du haut de
gamme de la
[Musique]
championne surprise tout le monde
Jess c'est comme ça que ça doit
être quel que soit le chemin que tu
choisis je te
soutiendrai je sais que est parfois
sauvage sexuellement je veux que tu
saches qu'il tient ça du côté de ma
famille je suis
désolé je vous remercie de partager ça
avec
moi c'est important qu'on reste connecté
pendant cette période intense des fait
de fin d'année alors tu déposes ses
guirlandes et tu sors ta